titanfall to pre-alpha tech test is open
if you got a ps4 or Xbox one you'll be
able to play this upcoming frenetic
shooter what's more the new game mode
bounty hunt this mode centers on two
teams generating cash from kills as well
as individual pilots cashing out bonuses
to deposit banks failure to do so can
result in a landslide loss simply put
always be caching so let's go through
some tips and better understand pilot
and Titan roles in the bounty hunt mode
first off let's talk about the practice
of conservation and a basic workflow to
follow when the grunts drop in the
middle of a match don't rush them at
point-blank obviously your goal is not
to die but get killed by a pilot that
pilot takes half of your bonus this
horrible truth means you need to make
one of two calls depending on how much
you're carrying if you're carrying more
than 300 bucks and the wave is 75%
complete consider booking it to the
nearest bank and wait for the bank to
open
that's your defensive approach now if
the round is about to end and you only
have ten bucks to your name cashing out
won't do your team any good your role
now is to swoop down on enemy pilots and
take what they have
but again once you're rocking a couple
hundred get out of there
remember you ain't making kills you're
making bills baby so the wave is over
and banks are open if you're still in
route to a bank stay out of the open if
you're not a parkour master say if
whatever tactical ability you're rocking
and time it for the last leg of your
approach pulse play that deposit area
grappled down from above consciously
save your best for last and if there
aren't any teammates around a bank don't
just rush in there offloading hundreds
take time meaning any desperate bum can
rob you and cash in your hard day's work
so check your corners first don't use
the front door on boomtown here take the
side windows and consider tossing a nade
when you're cashing out don't stand
there like a sitting duck engage the
deposit and circle it watching your back
once you're done become that broke bum
you hate just crouch in the shadows and
wait lastly you got your Titans as you
already know you need to exit your Titan
in order to cash out when you do so make
sure you're at a close distance to the
bank
do your best to position the Titan right
in front of the deposit bank and hit
that guard mode mopping up any
unsuspecting pilots coming in also
consider putting on the Titan assault
chip that increases Auto Titan lethality
even more if there's an infantry drop
zone phase going on get there throw your
Titan and guard mode and go spread
terror elsewhere and if you could rate
which Titan is the best farmer it'll
probably go to scorcher it's fire AoE on
grunts and spectres is an undeniable
moneymakers
well there you have it
those were just some of my initial tips
on time fall two is bounty hunt mode
again this is a pre-alpha build and is
subject to change but hopefully these
tips treat you well during the two
weekends of this tech test if you have
any pointers yourself feel free to put
them in the comments and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more titanfall 2
coverage thanks for watching
you